hey guys this is max also known as ren
harasaki and i'm here together with evan
langer
hello and we're here to break down the
newest trailer
of breath of the wild sequel uh coming
out in 2022
now we did a breakdown couple years ago
in 2019 after they did their first
teaser and this will be the follow-up to
that and breaking down what's new
that's come out in the newest footage
this is going to be a superficial
breakdown it's basically right after
the announcement and so it's not going
to be super in-depth we're just going to
see
what we can find and delve into right
after
what we saw in the nintendo direct 2021
okay so we see these tendrils of malice
that come up now we see a quick flash
of link getting looks like infected by
the mouse so this is
points of contention to talk about here
because that is the same arm that has
the kind of like zonaish white hand from
earlier in the in the
2019 teaser trailer that was used but
this is definitely something that's
strange because we don't know if it's an
evil entity
if it's a if it's a good entity so this
shot here this is
the first and last time we see zelda in
this teaser which is kind of a bummer
which
you know we wanted to have like zelda
and link together playable in breath of
the wild it doesn't seem like it's going
that route
it definitely seems more like zelda is
in peril again
after maybe the events of you guys going
down in that cavern and then link needs
to
save the day again which again is
unfortunate because it would be nice to
see a partner zelda
but uh you know as it goes with the
legend of zelda what may have happened
was
link and zelda both fell during this
time and link was grabbed by that
you know white entity that seal hand and
zelda was not
so that's just my guess just from
putting the two and two trailers
together
but we'll we won't know until the final
product comes out obviously
so this is probably your favorite part
where
this is a huge skyward sword reference
this is basically
straight out of skyward sword uh what do
you think of this shot
yeah i mean there's no context for this
shot i think like
what it because in skyward sword when
this happens it's when like you have the
loft wing right like you're jumping off
the loft wing um
but it excites me to know that there
might be some more skyward sword
connections and if they're re-releasing
skyward sword hd right now
or next month that would make a lot of
sense that they would be doing that to
get people like
in the know about everything about
skyward sword so when if this new game
is connected to it in a lot of ways
people will be up to speed on it again
this is also our first look at link's
new
outfit which is pretty cool well the
first thing that stuck out to me is
his new haircut he's got his hair down
you know letting it all out the hair
down look is pretty
pretty snazzy i like it a lot again we
haven't seen the front of his face
though with the hair down i'm kind of
curious to see what it looks like it's
always from the back
yeah so um again this also gives
huge uh vibes of an old uh technology
and kind of forgotten race called the
zonai in breath of the wild one
there's you know the ruins of the zonai
ruins um
in the far on area and there hasn't been
much talked about it officially really
in breath of the wild lore
but a lot of the stuff has the same
designs as the zonai
um especially like the rock formations
and whatnot so um
i'm guessing and this is just
theoretical thing this could be like a
zonai form
in breath of the wild one i was i
believe the berserkers outfit had the
same kind of
vibe and look as a zonai tribe member
again that wasn't anything
official official as far as i know this
could allude to
that kind of same design clothing-wise
totally and something that stuck out to
me
is on the shield you can see what looks
to be like a pattern of triforces and
in the original breath of the wild the
triforce didn't really play a huge role
in it all
um like you would just kind of assume
like link has the triforce occurred
zelda has the triforce wisdom blah blah
blah so i wonder if this new tribe is
involved
potentially living in the sky if the
triforce is going to play a big role in
the story of this game yeah it is a
subtle
detail on a shield here again it could
be uh shika probably not yiga because
it's not upside down but there's
definitely some sort of
new symbol here and with you know
repeating triforce symbols below that so
it's a new design it's that's pretty
much the night shield uh
pretty much reskinned as this new design
we don't know exactly what it means but
it's pretty cool
uh he does have a new bow and possibly a
new sword and look
we can't really tell the swords design
at this point it looks like a new sword
it's not the master sword that's first
definitely not the master sword that's
for dang sure where'd the master sword
go
you know what that's a good question we
don't really know where the master sword
went at this point because we don't know
if he got his full powers back from
breath of the wild one he may have kept
the master short with them or he may
have left it in
the lost woods we don't know but it's
never seen here in this trailer so it
may be not canon that he keeps it
one thing to note here i love the color
palette of this this kind of like yellow
autumn
uh fall look throughout the the island
top area
it's really nice looking i don't think
i've seen this kind of theme
in breath of the wild one early and like
the the foliage so
it is kind of a nice change of pace um
because we will obviously see the
original breath of the wild one
uh overworld and we're kind of tired of
that so another another new area like
this is definitely welcome for sure
i've been thinking about it is these
islands are pretty high up and
he's i don't think he has enough of an
angle at least since the original breath
of the wild to make that distance like
that so
it's either gonna be like uh random
updrafts that like carry to the next
island or
there'll be another mechanic later in
the trailer that'll show maybe how you
connect
from the ground to the islands um but
yeah just superficially he's not gonna
make any of these islands going like
this
no absolutely not so yeah i guess it'll
we'll see what ends up happening i
wonder if that paraglider maybe it is a
new paraglider in some way maybe it's
some fancy maybe his arm his new arm
abilities
touching the paraglider gives it some
magic superpowers who knows
next shot we see this enemy again it's
hard to say
if it's specifically zonai or completely
another new tribe or new technology
uh entirely but it's it's definitely got
something else that was not
really alive in breath of the wild one
that's going on here oh yeah i mean you
can see in the in the neck
that that energy going through it is the
same thing
from the original trailer that attacked
link that like greenish
turquoise so that power whatever it is
will definitely be playing a big role in
this game
all right so this shot this uh this
talus is pretty cool
uh obviously the the goblins are
it looks like they may have been
strengthened by this new
entity because there's no bokoblins
throughout the trailer that have smaller
horns
they've all grown horns now right um i
thought it was just specific to this
shot but it looks like all the bokoblins
later in the trailer
also um have larger horns yeah i mean my
my big question
after kind of watching this trailer and
seeing that like it'll take place
probably in the sky and the surface is
like
what does the what does the surface
world have to offer now right like we've
already
especially you have spent so much time
like on the surface of that game so it's
like
we see these like new pokoblins which
could potentially be harder with these
horns and they also have a base set up
on a stone talus which feels like it's a
huge challenge in and of itself um so
we don't really know anything about it
but just seeing it i think is just
really exciting to be like oh cool like
this is a whole new challenge like in
front of us in the surface and i i don't
know just by looking at it where on the
world that is
but i'm assuming more of that will crop
up all around the place
all of the shots with this new outfit
are in the sky and all of those outfits
that are old are on the ground so most
likely again this is my theory is that
later in the trailer there's like a
water drop that goes upwards and that's
his way to transport between the two
worlds
i believe that everything on the ground
will be vanilla link here with this
champions tunic you know a hyrulean
garb outfit mixture with the you know
ponytail back and when he goes upwards
into the sky is when he gets his
kind of zonais berserker outfit that's
the only thing that i can deduce from
this because
obviously there's both links but they're
both in the same game
right well the other part of it too it
could be it could be time travel
zelda is not adverse to or has not shied
away from time travel
in the past it's possible that maybe you
travel
as the player between like a future
world in the sky
and like a past world on the surface and
you could just jump between the two
um yeah like okay time style where it's
like you go between the child and adult
and those two kind of interlink in some
ways so yeah anything's possible but
i think they're definitely separated in
some way like you said
with breath of the wild uh you know time
travel is not out of the picture at this
point
um because there is something later in
the trailer that alludes to time travel
so it's not something that can be that's
just you know crazy theories from from
fans at this point it's actually could
be possible
this shot here is interesting because
this looks
pretty similar to link's position at the
very very beginning of breath of world
one where
he's laying down you see like a shot of
his hip and his underwear his new
underwear is snazzy underwear
hell yeah yeah it looks like he's got
that news like
ancient technology sealed zonai
again i was all quote unquote thing you
got
from the original 2019 teaser it's
definitely linked to that because those
designs on the side
are very similar to the ones that were
kind of crawling upwards towards the
camera
in the 2019 teaser so there's a whole
bunch of teasers kind of tying things
together but nothing concrete yet
so we'll only see more in the future on
what exactly this
this unfolds totally in hey link listen
i love you but uh i might want to groom
those fingernails buddy get a little
long
this is probably my my favorite part of
the trailer so far because i'm the
the game mechanics and combat guy and i
you know obviously at first blush i
thought this was stasis like oh stasis
is back this is great
and then look two seconds later it's
like oh that's definitely not stasis at
all
so uh looking back at that that is 100 a
time reverse mechanic
where he can reverse the effects of time
on a certain object and it'll go
back it'll be cool to see link kind of
move around in this form while you're
reversing time to see
that that'll be a great you know use of
the game mechanics and seeing where link
would be
and uh using that in the middle of
combat that'll be very cool alright this
next shot is really cool so he's got
like
some dragon's breath kind of shield
looking thing
i don't know if that actually works as a
proper shield but i don't think you can
actually
block with that as far as i can tell but
it is cool that you have some offensive
capabilities for the shield
um it's it's hard to tell if this is an
attachment for shield or if it's
actually just the shield itself that has
this ability
but it is pretty cool to see this uh
this available in the game
for me personally like seeing this like
dragon head attachment on the shield
that's really exciting because you know
with breath of the l i'm a i love
traditional zelda right i love having
traditional zelda items
i completely understand the decision why
they took those away in breath of the
wild and i think in that game it worked
really well to just have it the bare
bones of like
sword shield bow and arrow on top of you
know you could also get like a boomerang
um but with this like i feel like now
they're kind of pushing the envelope a
little bit which is really exciting like
we're not gonna give you probably all
traditional zelda items like a hook shot
and stuff but um we are gonna give you
this cool like fire breathing dragon
thing on the back of the shield and
especially in the shot here
you can see there's like a little
staircase leading like a little pedestal
so it's like you know is this like a
dungeon are we getting
zelda dungeons back um i love the
shrines in breath of the wild i hope we
get
more shrines like even up in the sky
maybe but i felt like the divine beasts
were just
bigger shrine so i'm hoping we do see
the return of like
zelda dungeon so like in this shot yeah
we get this cool fire breathing shield
thing
and maybe we're in a dungeon and there's
like this new enemy like to me that's
like
the implications of that if i'm unless
i'm reading too far into this but the
implications of it are very exciting
okay so the next shot we see here is
with this water droplet and then link
goes upwards and clips through
solid rock which is pretty cool this may
be pertaining to like a a new form of
travel as well because
there is no sheikah slate so he can't
properly teleport like he can in the
original
so this may be like the new version of i
guess it would be like a chica tower
where you can get height
up in the sky to travel to the next
place or alice skyward sword this is
like his way of like getting up into the
sky
kind of loft wing style to travel to a
new place as well we got to see how that
new system interacts with
everything that's new here as well as
the old stuff because like i said
earlier this is the old overworld that's
that's definitely somewhere in
breath of the wild one that you can go
to right now we will uh have some more
information
later obviously but as of right now it's
really not clear on how those systems
will interact with the old
overworld so this location is definitely
in breath of the wild there's like a
fallen pillar over a road
and that's got a new uh encampment enemy
encampment right at the left
bottom there so the overworld's been
changed
has been changed because if they had the
exact same vanilla breath of the wild
some of the mechanics wouldn't work and
obviously that'd be very boring
so i'm curious to see how much has
changed
but there's obviously some similar
overworld tones here
yeah only time will tell 20 20 22
will 20 20 tell i'm gonna go quit my job
now
[Laughter]
so as he said 2022 um
again this could be march to celebrate
the
the same time as breath of the wild's
original or uh
it could be december 31st which would be
a huge bummer because that's like a year
you know year and a half away but 2022
that's what they said
um hopefully it doesn't get delayed but
we will have some more information
when it comes out so that was our
superficial breakdown of breath of the
wild what did you think of what you saw
so far
you know i i'm a huge zelda fan i'm
extremely excited for this game
but i will admit like nintendo revealing
this in 2019
and going silent for two years and then
coming back with like
a minute and a half trailer that just
says like you have another year year and
a half to wait like it's hard to
to continue that excitement it's hard to
i mean definitely like
we've gained all these new implications
from this trailer who knows if a lot of
that stuff will come true
so i don't know i love zelda i'm excited
for this game but i don't know this this
new trailer didn't really
evoke a lot in me i'm more just like
okay like you've already sold me on it i
already trust that this game is gonna be
incredible
i'm just i'm ready for it now i'm ready
to just get that full blowout whether
that be later this year or
early next year or whenever yeah i'm
somewhat the same the the
the trailer was definitely hyped for me
but we know we thought we saw this in
2019 and i was thinking oh there's gonna
be a majora's mask turnaround with the
same assets we're gonna have it next
year
you know 2022 is it's been a while now
and
breath of the wild's development started
very soon after breath of the wild
finished
um even i believe even during the dlc
development time
so and they said they had a lot of new
ideas coming to this game
that they had so many ideas from the
breath of the wild original they had to
pour it over into the next game
so they have lots of new ideas coming i
just haven't seen too much of that so
far especially with
the same overworld being present um i i
just have to see
the proper game in my hands and this
hasn't shown
too much but it has just teased just
enough for us to break down this
um what we saw today yeah and you know
the the interesting part to me i know
covet definitely could have impacted
development and you know all the love
and support to the developers to take as
long as they need to make
another incredible zelda game but you
know i believe
unless i'm mistaken breath of the wild's
development started in like 2012 like
very shortly after skyward sword was
finished in 2011.
so if you think about it that way that
was five years between 2012 and 2017. so
it will now be an
additional five years between the sequel
and like you said we all thought back in
2019 this might just be like
you know a lot of the same assets and
and physics and world that they had
built for breath the wild
just being applied to two but now it's
seeming like they're taking
just as much time to make this one so
like
not to you know i'll give them the
benefit of the doubt in a lot of ways
but it's like i'm expecting a lot now
if they took just as much time to make
two as they did to make one
covered aside you know hopefully they'll
be just a lot of cool new stuff that
makes this very different from the
original in a lot of ways and
worth the wait so that was our breakdown
to sequel of legend of zelda breath of
the wild's new 2021 teaser
we will be patiently waiting on 2022 to
see the the game come out
if there's anything more you guys want
from us from breath of the wild to or
even the original breath of the wild
definitely let us know down in the
comments but on the 16th and 17th of
this month
we'll be hosting play for all two days
of live programming where we have
developer interviews
exclusive trailers and we're just gonna
have a fun time so definitely tune in
on the 16th and 17th of this month
anyways thanks for watching we'll be
here again when nintendo drops more new
news for the sequel to legend of zelda
breath of the wild
[Music]
you